PATRICE BERGERON AND
SIDNEY CROSBY
HE GETS HIS FIRST
TOUCH AND HANDLES
FIRST, AND FRFRERENCE
MAKER BY PLAYING THIS
KIND OF HOCKEY.WRIST SHOT
>> Andy: WE GOSS ANGLES
>> Andy: IS LOOKING H TO McAVOY
CRACKS IT TO THE TAPE.S
THROUGH THE WICKETSFRED
BATTLES  MATHESON ON
THE BOARDS..TER.
GREAT BACKCHECK BY
THE FOUR TIMES SULKY
AWARD WI. GETS IT AWAY
.
>> JACK: HE GETS HIS
STICK IN CROSBY SKATE
McAVOY TO DEBRUSK.
MARCHAND
EVERYTHING BUT
. FOLIGNOARRIVE
AT THE START LINE.
ADDED PRESSURE ON
TAMPA BAY ,
CARLOS STEALS.YSICALLY
THIS AFTERNOON.
THAT PUMP WAS LAZAR'S
HITS, AND  THOUGHT HE H
ON THE FAR SIDE, BUT
THE BRUINS WERE
CHANGING OUT ONE OF JUN.
CROSBY TO LETANG. GET T,
ROLLING ALL THE Andy:
ALWAYS TOUGH TO TELL
CLIFTON PINS THE PUCK
TO THE CORNER BOARDS.
FORMER. ENTER NOT
THE PUCK BLOCKED.
LATERALLY, CROSBY
BACK TO PETTERSSON. LE
RAKELL . CROSBY IS
OFF THAT FA GREG SMITH
IT FREE.
THOUGHT HE
COULD GO BA TRIES
TO SLIDE IT
UNDERNEATH C
AND THEN HEINEN  CROSBY
HIGH LOB INTO THE
NEUTRAL ZONE,  AND